what is the difference between sahabat and chakra what is translated as patience and complaining
one of the things to keep in mind is that the concept and the idea of
patience and the word patience itself is not the greatest translation for summer in the Arabic
language why because Soviet as we know it is to refrain or detain or stop something
from happening in the religious context it's to hold oneself back from something that is detrimental
so during times of hardship for example you are holding yourself back and refraining from saying
or doing that which is displeasing to Allah as for complaining there are two different types
of complaints there is complaining to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and the example that we have
is from the Quran nama ash kuba 'they were hosni in allah yahoo bali he said
i'm said i complained of my grief and my hardship to allah subhanho wa taala so
you are asking upon allah subhanaw taala are you allowed to say oh Allah I call
upon you and I am weak and I'm complaining to you of my weakness it is
permissible based on some authentic narrations as well and Allah knows best but with regards to
the second type it is complaining about our problems our decrees our issues to other people
where are the guidelines here we want to be consistent with our gratitude to Allah but
at the same time we realize yes it is permissible to go ask for advice from
other people it is permissible to speak about our problems but not in a way in
which we are complaining about our fate our blessings and so on and so forth rather
in terms of seeking advice from those who have experience or those who can relate or
those who can advise us and be there for us but generally speaking we complain of
our problems to allah subhana wa ta'ala asking him with our weakness for help because he
is on lawsuit on Owatonna the exalted and allah knows best